Yeah,
right there.
Okay.
Get ready to go.
Let the computer away.
Here's the keys.
Wallet.
You got the phone.
Got To get my nice shoes with them on.
Just ready to go.
Yeah.
I mean I just,
he's my friend now.
Right?
Ready to go.
It's bringing this up.
Joseph.
Much appreciate it.
Um,
until uh,
for 20,
25,
30 years.
Thank you so much for us.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you.
I had to go get on the Lawrence
O'donnell show.
You got the backstage pass.
Okay.
That'd be great.
Waterman.
Okay,
cool.
Thank you.
When you go see you in the green room
for now and after he kicked me out,
mirror say is the right time to do the
right thing and all those other
products.
It's Chris,
but I think a big news event would be
like tsunami kind of thing.
That would be like,
you can't not talk about it the whole
time.
This is big.
This is big for MSNBC.
It's nice to be properly laid.
I must say.
Oh No.
Television has a strange power.
Especially in American culture.
It lends credibility,
instant credibility to people that
sometimes don't want to.
Absolutely true.
Right.
Hello everyone.
I am here in the studio where I will be
recording.
Hello everyone.
I'm here in the studio where we're.
I'm here in the studio.
Where will we be?
Where I will be recording.
Hello everyone.
I'm here in the studio where I will be
recording my segment on the last word.
This is a little studio that they,
they got us in right here.
I got this earpiece in my ear.
I can hear the host,
Melissa Harris Perry talking right now.
That's the camera that we'll be filming
us and this is the little tvs where we
are.
I can see myself,
which I have asked them to turn off
because as I said that my first flog,
I cannot not look at myself.
Um,
so we're waiting right now listening to
Melissa do the show,
but she's going to,
uh,
uh.
Hi Evan.
How are you?
Good,
how are you,
Melissa?
Oh,
we were absolutely blown away by your
video.
Can I tell you?
We had been emailing it to one another
and playing it over and over again.
What inspired you to make it?
Well,
I was watching last night when Lauren
said,
you know,
it was the simplicity of the idea and I,
I completely agree with that,
but I think it's that plus the fact that
it's something that you,
you don't think of,
you know,
and that's what struck me when I
originally heard them announce it a year
ago on the show,
is it something that you never think of?
And so it sort of hits you in that,
that feel bad Oregon,
whatever that is.
And you,
you get that reflexive feeling like he
said last night to donate.
So it was uploaded five days ago and
you've gotten more than 200,000
hits.
What is,
what has been the reaction you've been
getting from people online who have seen
it?
The reaction has been,
I use the word aggressively generous.
It is.
The comments just on the video has been
like donated.
They just say donate or they say,
you know,
I just took a kid off the floor and
Malawi.
And to know that you could possibly kind
of do make that effect in the world by
making a video is it,
is truly incredible.
Now,
speaking of that,
I mean it's a small,
small thing and desks.
It's a small thing to make a video.
So.
So what is your ultimate goal though?
So you have this small thing,
but then you have a video that
Crescendos to winning the Nobel prize.
What was your Christian?
No,
here.
What,
what would you like this video to do?
What I would like it to do is it was a,
um,
it was a video for the project for
awesome,
which is a youtube charity event that
happens every year where people make
videos on the charity of their choice.
They submit them,
the community watches them.
It's hosted by John and Hank Green of
the vlog brothers.
We just have a lot of people at their
disposal online and we all donated to
the project for awesome.
I think it raised about $71,000.
And what we're waiting for now is the
top voltage charities are going to get
some of that money.
They're going to be divvied up based on
what the votes are and the ultimate goal
for this is to get some more money for
the kind fund because we could actually
make a huge difference.
I'm getting getting classrooms,
you know,
not just kids,
but classrooms off the floor.
Well,
and then the video is indeed awesome and
all I have absolutely no authority to do
so.
I got to tell you,
that's a good enough video that I don't
know.
Maybe somebody ought to be talking to
you here at Msnbc coming up.
That was a great video.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
Thanks Evan Lawrence,
the entire last word team.
All of us.
Thank you for your help.
Now you can find it.
Got It.
Thank you very much.
Have a nice day.
Okay.
Spot is over.
I'm sweating at the armpits.
You can't see because I'm wearing two
shirts.
Let's,
let's get out here.
So we just finished building it.
Pacific television studios did the
segment.
I think it went great.
I was really nervous.
It went by so fast.
She was really nice,
extremely,
you know,
gracious and I just tried to gracious
back and I hope we watch it tonight and
it looks good and you can't see the
sweat from under my arm.
So thank you very much for tuning in.
Back to the limo.